after the celebrations ended last night
the fireworks continued across the
valley causing many fires and injuries
eight news now's reporter Brian will
digging into the aftermath of illegal
fireworks
oh this is all the time every year
almost non-stop with the um Fireworks
but I think this is what did it Ronald
Scott is one of the many residents who
suffered damage to his property because
of fireworks while fines and enforcement
increased it didn't stop illegal
fireworks Clark County fire chief John
Steinbeck says we have a 1400 percent
increase in fires year after year
and you know so we we know that bulk of
those are from fireworks fire Crews were
quite busy during the Fourth of July
holiday responding to more than 60 tree
fires and multiple fires across the
valley yeah everything's gone
every everything within Clark County a
39 year old had severe burns to his face
people lost their homes and fire Crews
responded to more than a hundred calls
after dark on Tuesday some preventative
measures with Metro did help in stopping
illegal fireworks from getting into the
county helped us collect over 2 500
pounds of
fireworks however we have six teams out
there during the Fourth of July season
we rode over 60 or we wrote 61 citations
and if I we had a hundred teams they'd
all be busy when looking ahead to next
year Chief Steinbeck says there needs to
be new Solutions and want people to
continue to report illegal fireworks we
always have hope right do I have a
realistic expectation and next year this
won't be a problem no I don't